يوم لا شك فيه أنه تاريخي
يتكشف في حديقة البيت الأبيض حيث
استضاف الرئيس دونالد ترامب رئيس
الوزراء الإسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
ووزراء خارجية
الإمارات العربية المتحدة والبحرين
للتوقيع على اتفاقيات التطبيع التي
تجلب العلاقات التي كانت
وراء الكواليس لسنوات و  ربما بعد
عقود من الانفتاح ،
فإن العامل الرئيسي الدافع بين هذه
الاتفاقيات هو تحالف فعال
مناهض لإيران بين دول الخليج السنية
وإسرائيل ترامب ، ويصف رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو هذا التحول
في المنطقة
بأنه تحول نحو السلام نتنياهو قائلاً إن
هذا كان
سلامًا لـ  السلام ونتيجة لقوة إسرائيل.
يذكر أن
وزير خارجية الإمارات العربية المتحدة
يقول إن أحد الأجزاء المهمة في ذلك
هو وقف ضم إسرائيل
لأجزاء من الضفة الغربية
ووقف ضم
الأراضي الفلسطينية ، وعلى الرغم من أن
الفلسطينيين لم يكونوا كذلك.
هناك واتهموا كلاً من الإمارات والبحرين
بخيانة القانون  حد ذاتها وخيانة
القدس ،
هذا لا يبقي على قيد الحياة إمكانية
حل الدولتين
كما لاحظت البحرين والإمارات العربية المتحدة
جانبًا مهمًا من هذا الجانب لكل من
الدول العربية التي تقول إنها لا تزال
ملتزمة بمبادرة السلام العربية التي تقودها السعودية عام 2002
نتنياهو و  ترامب يعد بأن هناك
المزيد من الدول العربية
التي تنتظر في طابور ربما
قريبًا لتطبيع العلاقات مع
إسرائيل وإخراج تلك
العلاقات إلى الواجهة ولكن كان هناك
فحص للواقع في منتصف ذلك
حيث بدأ وزير الخارجية الإماراتي
يتحدث عن إطلاق صواريخ
سقط صاروخان من غزة في مدينة عسقلان الإسرائيلية ،
صاروخان على وجه الدقة
وفقًا للجيش الإسرائيلي ،
أحد الصواريخ التي اعترضها
نظام الدفاع الجوي الإسرائيلي ذو القبة الحديدية ،
لذا على الرغم من أن هذا يجلب إلى الواجهة
العلاقات بين البلدان التي
لم تكن في حالة حرب أبدًا ، هناك بالطبع بالطبع.
لا تزال الصراعات الدائرة في المنطقة
مثل تلك بين غزة وإسرائيل واحدة
من الأسئلة الكبيرة المعلقة على
سير  كان إيموني بالطبع فيروس كورونا ،
ستعود إسرائيل إلى الإغلاق
بعد فترة وجيزة من عودة نتنياهو إلى
البلاد بسبب سوء
أرقام فيروس كورونا هنا ،
ربما تكون أول دولة في العالم
تعيد فرض إغلاق عام
بسبب الوضع
4973 حالة جديدة يوم الاثنين.  سجل
وفقًا للأرقام التي قدمتها
وزارة الصحة أحد
الأسئلة الرئيسية حيث حضر نتنياهو هذا
الحفل في حديقة البيت الأبيض
هل كان يرتدي قناعًا ، هل
سيكون هناك تباعد اجتماعي
بين السؤالين بشكل قاطع لا
ويمكن أن يؤدي ذلك بشكل سيئ للغاية هنا لأن
نتنياهو لديه  تم الترويج له وشدد على
أهمية ارتداء القناع
والتباعد الاجتماعي شيئين
غائبين بشكل ملحوظ
في حفل البيت الأبيض بسرعة كبيرة
سيتعين على نتنياهو التحول من
الاحتفالات في واشنطن مع
الوضع المحلي هنا
ارتفاع معدلات البطالة والاحتجاجات المستمرة
وهذا
الإغلاق العام الثاني يلوح في الأفق فقط  بعد
يومين اورين ليبرمان
cnn القدس